-President Trump used his trip
to Europe
to enrich himself as calls
for his impeachment grew louder.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
President Trump
is back in the U.S.
fresh off his European tour
of doing and saying dumb things
in important places.
[ Laughter ]
Whenever Trump goes abroad,
it's like seeing
all the worst habits of American
tourists rolled into one person.
The only thing he didn't do
was show up to the Louvre
in sandals
and Mickey ears
holding a McFlurry.
[ Laughter ]
This trip was no exception.
Trump once again brought
his signature weirdness
to some of the world's
most famous landmarks.
He gave the Queen another one
of his clammy handshakes.
He went to Buckingham Palace
to re-enact a scene
from the movie "Tommy Boy."
[ Laughter ]
And he tried on a
Winston Churchill-style
bowler hat during an interview
on British television.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's pretty obvious
that British reporters
just like to make him do things
to make him look silly.
[ British accent ] Like,
"Right, now, try on this hat.
And now dance,
dance with the hat on.
And now give us a little twirl.
Give us a little twirl.
Now you look fancy!"
[ Laughter ]
You know, I never thought I'd
say this,
but your hair looks better
than you in a hat.
[ Laughter ]
You don't look like
Winston Churchill.
You look like Dick Tracy
minus the Tracy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course,
one of the biggest highlights --
One of the biggest highlights
of Trump's trip was his stop
at Normandy to commemorate
the 75th anniversary of D-Day.
Now during his prepared remarks,
Trump stayed on script and it
was a moving and solemn tribute.
Afterwards however,
in an unscripted meeting
with French President Emmanuel
Macron,
Trump tried to describe
in his own terms
the historical significance
of Normandy
and he was a little
less specific.
-This was a very special day.
And I want to thank you
for inviting me.
This was something that was --
We read about it all our lives,
Normandy.
And there were those that say
it was the most important ever.
Not just at that time, but ever.
But it's a very special place.
It's an amazing place.
And it's somewhere
when you think of those places
of great importance, this is
certainly one of the top.
In the eyes of summits,
the top
because of what it meant
in terms of the turn-around
of a very, very bad situation.
That was the big turn.
-I love how the camera pulls
back like it's trying to see
if there's someone else in the
room who knows what the [bleep]
is going on.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, he sounds like
he's doing voiceover
for the History Channel,
but then he spilled coffee
on his script.
[ Laughter ]
And then there was Trump's trip
to Ireland
where he met with
the Irish Prime Minister
and discussed the impact
of Brexit
on the border between Ireland
and the independent republic in
Northern Ireland,
which is part of the U.K.
Right now, there's
an open border there.
The absolute last thing
anyone wants there is a wall.
So naturally,
Trump said something
about having a wall there.
A comment that was so dumb,
the prime minister of Ireland
had to correct him.
-I think it will all work out,
it will all work out very well.
And also for you with your wall,
your border.
I mean,
we have a border situation
in the United States
and you have one over here.
But I hear it's going
to work out very well.
I think it is supposed
to work out well.
It's going to work out
very well here.
-The main thing we want to
avoid, of course, is been to
border our wall between --
-No. I think you do.
I think you do.
The way it works now is good.
You want to try to keep it
that way.
-I love when Trump pretends
he knew the right answer
the whole time.
[ As Trump ] You need a wall.
[ Irish accent ]
We don't want a wall.
[ As Trump ]
No, yeah, you don't, no.
No, I knew that.
I was testing you.
You pass. Congratulations.
[ Laughter ]
You passed.
I'm smart, and you passed.
[ Normal voice ] Seriously,
this guy is unbelievable.
These countries are in the
middle of an extremely delicate
diplomatic situation involving
a landmark peace accord
that ended decades
of sectarian conflict.
And Trump just bursts in
and immediately says
the wrong thing. He's the Kramer
of international diplomacy.
[ Laughter ]
But Trump didn't just go
to Ireland --
[ Applause ]
Trump didn't just go to Ireland
to make Brexit bloopers.
He also went there to enrich
himself on the taxpayers' dime
by staking yet another one
of his personal properties,
a golf course he owns in Ireland
called Doonbeg.
In fact, "Huffington Post"
reported that the trip
to his golf course in Ireland
added at least another $3.6
million
to a taxpayer-funded golf tab
that totals nearly $106 million
from just two and a half years.
And the resort in Ireland even
began posting video
of Trump's arrival
aboard Marine One
and of him teeing off
the first green
in its promotional material.
And on top of that,
they charged us for the hat.
[ Laughter ]
Trump also toted his weird adult
sons around him even though...
[ Laughter ]
...they don't work
for the government
and they run
the family business,
which is supposed to be
independent
from the White House.
They were even posting Instagram
photos from the trip
like this shot Don Jr. posted
from Buckingham Palace.
Once again, why do these guys
stand like such weirdos?
[ Laughter ]
Did he forget to take the hanger
out of his jacket?
He's like an alien
who crash-landed on Earth
and learned how to stand up
straight
by looking at a Ken doll.
[ Laughter ]
I've seen dogs
that look more natural
standing on their hind legs.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Even if you put aside
the 400 page Mueller report
and the mountains of evidence
that Trump obstructed justice,
Trump's self-dealing
should be a huge scandal.
The president is enriching
himself on the taxpayers' dime
and mixing his personal business
with the government.
Compare that to previous
presidents who went
to great lengths to separate
themselves from their businesses
in order to avoid even
the appearance
of a conflict of interest.
-Jimmy Carter famously put his
peanut farm into a blind trust
to avoid any suggestion
that he might ever implement
a policy that would benefit
himself financially.
-Jimmy Carter put his peanut
farm in a blind trust.
Could you imagine if Trump
had a peanut farm?
He'd be holding rallies there
and selling jars
of peanut butter
with the presidential seal
on them.
I mean, he already looks like
a peanut company mascot.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you ask Trump if the border
wall would be made of steel
or concrete, he'd say we're
making the wall out of...
-Peanuts!
-In many ways, this is all part
of the same story with Trump.
Whether it's his self-dealing
or the 400 pages of evidence
in the Mueller report,
Trump's main interest
is always enriching himself.
And now, there's increasing
pressure from Democrats
in Congress in running
for President
to begin impeachment hearings.
Massachusetts Senator Elizabeth
Warren made her case
for impeachment again
during a town hall last week.
-Do you believe still that
impeachment is the right path
forward and why or why not?
-Yes, I do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Mueller report came out
and the afternoon it came out, I
sat down and started reading it.
And I read it all afternoon,
I read it all night, I read it
into the next morning --
All 448 pages.
Donald Trump as President
delayed, deflected, moved,
fired, and did everything
he could to obstruct justice.
If he were any other person
in the United States,
based on what's documented
in that report,
he would be carried out
in handcuffs.
Now --
[ Applause ]
-I love that she said Trump
would be carried out
because you know that's how they
would have to do it.
[ Laughter ]
If the feds ever came for Trump,
he would lie down on the floor
like a kid
who doesn't want
to go to school.
And they'd have to lift him out
with a crane
like when they transfer
beluga whales at SeaWorld.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] Where are you
going to set me down?
[ Normal voice ] And yet in the
face of these increasing calls
for impeachment, some Democratic
leaders in the House,
and in particular,
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
have been resistant.
Last week, Pelosi tried
to mollify calls for impeachment
by saying she would rather
see Trump in jail.
-House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
escalating her war of words
against the president.
"Politico" reporting that during
a meeting Tuesday,
she was pressed by Judiciary
Committee Chairman Jerry Nadler
to start impeachment
proceedings.
NBC News has learned from
a congressional source
in the room, Pelosi then said
about the president,
"I don't want to see him
impeached.
I want to see him in prison."
-What does that mean?
If you think there's enough
evidence to put him in jail,
then there is enough evidence
for him to lose his job.
If you caught an employee
stealing cash from the register,
you wouldn't say,
"You'll go to jail for this!
But until that day, I'll see you
at the company picnic!"
[ Laughter ]
Now it will not shock you to
learn that after that comment,
Trump and his allies lashed out
at Pelosi.
First, Trump himself attacked
her in a series of tweets
and an interview on Fox News.
-"Nervous Nancy Pelosi
is a disgrace to herself
and her family for having made
such a disgusting statement,
especially since I was with
foreign leaders overseas."
-I think she's a disgrace.
I actually don't think
she's a talented person.
She is a nasty, vindictive,
horrible person.
But Nancy Pelosi,
I call her Nervous Nancy.
Nancy Pelosi is a disaster.
And she made a statement.
It was a horrible, nasty,
vicious statement.
-When you were overseas.
-While I'm overseas.
Now if I made any statement
about anybody,
it would be like a -- why would
he do that when he's overseas?
-You're doing it right now!
[ Laughter ]
You just did it.
Trump does this weird thing
where he predicts headlines
as he's making those headlines.
It's like a local news reporter
holding a match
and a bottle of kerosene
over a graphic
that says "House fire in
the Bronx. More at 11:00."
[ Laughter ]
Also, you call her
"Nervous Nancy?"
You sweat like
a high school sophomore
who crapped his pants
in math class
and just got called
to the chalkboard.
Then there was Trump booster
Sean Hannity
who without a hint of irony
claimed Pelosi had gone too far
by calling for Trump
to be jailed.
-Speaker Pelosi now apparently
telling senior Democrats
she would like to see
Trump behind bars.
Based on no actual crime,
she wants a political opponent
locked up in prison?
That happens in banana
republics.
Beyond despicable behavior.
-Hey, man,
where were you during all those
"Lock her up" chants?
Oh, right, you were
at those rallies!
[ Laughter ]
I mean, look at these two.
This looks like the end
of one of those fundraisers
where they auction off a date
with two bachelors
nobody wants to bid on.
-[ As Trump ] $10, $5.
I'll wear my tiny tuxedo.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Impeachment will give Democrats
the opportunity to marshal
all the evidence against Trump
in public and tell a story
about his corruption
that ties everything together.
Because right now, Trump is
obstructing and stonewalling
Congress on almost every front.
All he's giving them is --
-Peanuts!
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪